[Music]
I've chosen my bad boys Dirty Dozen this
is the team who work in my pilot
business guys tomorrow
[Music]
okay here's the good news do the final
12 congratulations each and every one of
you put back into this prison
you are the first 12 to get this
business going
it's not about pissing around with
glitter this is real and it's gonna get
tougher we're running a business you're
gonna learn yeah you're gonna earn I'm
gonna put back inside to this prison
how's that you feel can't wait to start
Grafton you know on it again in the
kitchen start cooking a lot of these
prisoners
we all need tough love it's like the
love your mum will give you I remember
wearing prison we need to be bloody told
off this is my first day teaching the
bad boys brigade to get more done I've
radically changed these prisoners
routine they're eating in the kitchen
not in their cells
the guys will lock up here they know
they know when they're gonna get out
their cell they know what time they're
gonna be locked up any change to that it
messes the system like meshes were there
[Music]
when things change I spend when things
start going wrong
sure enough here
I appreciate you
okay listen we're not stop arguing there
what is it listen is a big difference
between talking to each other and
shouting each other is talk nicely and
let's remember we're a team as soon as
their routine and the minute you change
one little thing bang they're like a
bunch of [ __ ] babies you're just
realizing what a shambles this so-called
brigade is turning out to be I don't
think he's gonna hang on to them their
act against any kind of authority really
when they're told to do something to
stand a chance of getting this scheme to
work in the time I've got we need to be
selling a product to the public in four
weeks time I want to prove these guys
that they can work together as they use
so I've got a plan but it it's a very
ambitious plan that could make or break
them and we'll put them under intense
pressure and get them to cook an entire
meal for the whole prison